venom comes from the director of
Zombieland ruben fleischer and stars Tom
Hardy as Eddie Brock who becomes venom
eventually when the alien symbiote bonds
with him spider-man has always been
super important to me ever since I was a
child I've always loved this character
and venom has always been my favorite
spider-man villain and it was very
crushing to me to see a kind of
wishy-washy portrayal of him in
spider-man 3 and he's just never really
gotten a good rap and this film
especially had a very difficult time
getting the theaters and so I'm a
supporter of this and I was pulling for
this even though I didn't think the
trailers looked any good I didn't like
this movie at all I think that it's a
massive misfire there are a lot of
scenes throughout the film however that
give you a hint at what this film could
have been some of my favorite aspects of
the film are the back and forth between
Eddie Brock and venom the personality
inside of him and the arguments they
have seeing Eddie Brock try to interact
with people try to be a normal person
while this voice is screaming inside of
his head trying to calm this side of him
down while also interacting in everyday
life very entertaining that aspect of
the movie I would love to see more of I
would like to see quite a bit more of
that personality struggle but you don't
really get that much of that it kind of
reminded me of a vocalization
of what we saw Otto Octavius deal with
in spider-man 2 when he's talking to the
arms and they're giving him ideas in his
head
we just don't hear those ideas out loud
now in venom we get to see and hear
venom interacting with Eddie Brock and
it adds a lot of humor to the film and
that's about where it ends for me in
regards to positives Tom Hardy's good
and the interaction between Eddie and
venom the action scenes were a big
letdown and that's one of the things
that I am most critical about when it
comes to venom this film is that action
scenes competent ones when you have
Studios like Sony behind your project
should not be that hard to accomplish
and here they just feel workman like
they feel like action scenes we've seen
a thousand times there's nothing really
to differentiate it from
other action scenes except for the fact
that there's venom in the middle of it
and he doesn't really do anything unique
and a major major issue here is that we
have a pg-13 rating and most fans
including myself were really pushing for
an R rating I mean we live in a world
now where Deadpool 1 and 2 and Logan
were extremely successful there's no
reason this film should be pg-13 but the
rumor is is that Sony was hoping that in
the future they could tie it into other
Marvel movies and spider-man movies are
usually not rated R and so we have to
create a universe that feels like it's
cohesive which to me is bullshit it's a
financial reason for making a product
that isn't as good as it could be and
that's what this film feels like to me a
product and those action scenes with
venom almost exclusively take place at
night now look at venom what color is he
black put him against the night sky you
really can't tell what the hell's going
on
and most of the action scenes feel like
that a big colossal CGI blur Riz Ahmed
is Carlton Drake I found very miscast
he's a gifted actor he was amazing in
Nightcrawler
but here as this very angry intimidating
businessman who's very into science and
really wants to create something new
apparently for the good of humanity well
he's also just this really cold person
who does not care if someone dies and
likes to use homeless people to
experiment on he just didn't really sell
that but this leads me really to my
biggest problem with the film the
villain could be considerably better if
the script gave him better things to say
and do because this is a very jumbled
screenplay that goes many different
places the tones don't always work it
goes from being a very funny film to
almost a horror film that feels like
body horror kind of David Cronenberg
esque but it's so glossy and Hollywood
iced and CGI heavy it really the best
way I can describe it is if you just
look at the amazing spider-man 1 & 2 it
feels like it fits in in that universe
all these blue laboratories and it just
doesn't look real it looks fabricated
and that script does this movie no
favors it feels like scenes were
filmed and then rewritten and filmed
again but then they don't match up with
things that have already been said the
film feels like it came off of a
conveyor belt and for some people that
might be exactly what you want you might
really want a scene where venom grabs a
goon and eats him but they cut away from
all of that and you just see someone's
reaction to it if that's the type of
movie you want to see then go ahead and
enjoy venom but as someone who expects a
lot more out of people who have the
rights to this character this was just
massively disappointing for me but
Michelle Williams - a fantastic actress
has such a thankless role with hardly
any screen time she had more screen time
in Halloween h2o I'm gonna give venom a
c-minus also Sony you have got to stop
putting things in trailers that are very
important to the film just stop if
you've seen the trailer for this movie
just like the amazing spider-man 2 you
have seen very specific parts of the
film that are meant to be important you
can go into the movie see the tension of
something set up and you're thinking in
your head I've seen this entire scene in
the trailer it's sad it really is all
that being said I do want to give a
major thank you to the sponsor for this
video Wix comm Wix is great because they
have hundreds of gorgeous and
professional templates and designs to
choose from you have total creative
freedom to make your website whatever
fits with you and your brand Wix is also
super technologically advanced so you
don't have to worry about being a whiz
at building websites you also have
access to unlimited pages and top-grade
hosting which is really a necessity for
every website owner this is the home
page for my dark forest pictures website
which is the production company that I
started when I was 14 years old that I'm
now turning into a real company to
produce short films and hopefully
feature films in Ohio and help boost the
freedom of the independent creators in
my home state and pretty soon you're
gonna have a lot more information on
this website about future films that I'm
hopefully able to develop and so if you
go to this website that I've linked here
you can learn more about how you can
create your own Wix website
but I'm very thankful to Wix for
allowing me to create that website and
for making it be a fun experience please
do visit the website
linked here to learn more about how you
can create a website of your own guys
thank you so much as always for watching
look forward to more reviews very soon
and if you like this you can click right
here and get stuck mine eyes
[Music]